[Music]
neurons in our nervous system use
electrical impulses to transmit
information throughout our bodies
this process is mediated by membrane
proteins called voltage-gated ion
channels
voltage-gated ion channels open and
close in reaction to changes in membrane
voltage
or membrane potential a cell membrane
potential
is generated by concentration gradients
of positively charged
sodium and potassium ions across the
membrane
when a neuron is at rest its ion
channels are closed
and the overall concentrations of ions
and proteins create a higher potential
on the outside
and a lower potential on the inside
this state is referred to as resting
potential
and the membrane is said to be polarized
to transmit a signal the neuron creates
an action potential
which travels down the axon
the action potential is mediated by the
opening of the voltage-gated sodium
channels
which allows sodium to enter the neuron
this depolarizes the membrane in that
local area
neurons then repolarize the membrane in
several ways
first voltage-gated sodium channels
close and become inactivated
then to counteract the positive charge
of the sodium ions
potassium channels open to allow
potassium ions to exit
lowering the voltage across the membrane
in this way the signal travels along the
neuron
sodium channels open and trigger one
another to generate action potentials
and potassium channels prime the neuron
for the next signal by allowing
potassium to exit
after the signal has finished the
locations of ions have been reversed
sodium concentration is high on the
inside and potassium concentration is
high on the outside
the sodium and potassium pump restores
the sodium and potassium gradients
making the cell ready to send another
signal
with each pumping cycle this transport
protein moves two potassium ions back
into the cell
and three sodium ions out of the cell
because the pump moves these ions
against their concentration gradients
it requires the energy of one atp
molecule for each cycle
this molecular machine comprises three
chains alpha beta and gamma
within the alpha chain three domains a p
and n
form the core engine of the pump the
pumping cycle occurs in several steps
with atp bound in the end site and the
transmembrane region open into the cell
the pump binds three sodium ions from
the cytoplasm
this causes the np and a sites to shift
closer together
with the help of a magnesium co-factor
the p-site is phosphorylated
and adp is cleaved off
leads to a conformational change that
exposes the sodium ions to the outside
the sodium ions can then be released one
after another into the extracellular
space
in this ion empty state the pump allows
the entry of two potassium ions
this causes dephosphorylation of the
pump followed by closing of the
extracellular gate
and allows the end domain to accept atp
again
as a result of atp binding the
intracellular gate opens
the potassium ions are released into the
cytoplasm and the cycle can start again
the sodium potassium pump is a key
protein that works to maintain the
sodium potassium gradients and intra and
extracellular potential differences
necessary for neuronal signaling
roughly a third of the atp made daily by
our cells
is spent to power this molecular machine
[Music]
you